I saw a picture of you quite striking
you and David Beckham in a tub you want
to explain what's happening here well we
were just relaxing as we often do and
that we didn't know that there was a
photograph being paper we really look
stunned yeah someone said hey guys no no
like we were just relaxing at the end of
a day like we often do so yeah there's
nothing more to it than that he's on our
show next Monday oh really
next Monday night it's him and Claire
Danes and Bob Odenkirk on the same couch
so that's gone right yeah he's a
wonderful guy I know we were shooting a
sketch for a big charity thing at home
called comic relief which is a wonderful
charity which ever if it ever comes to
America it's a great night and you would
love it and we shot a sketch together
he's a very kind man your picture of
being in a tub of the with a guy from
the UK is better than my in a tub with a
British guy picture
[Applause]
I think you win Ricky Ricky's Ricky
knows what he's doing in the top he did
know yeah good sense to scissors yeah
yeah nothing what'd you say Oh where's
the soap yeah yeah Ricky goes yes it
does doesn't it think about it yeah
you